my god reason the spectators are
extremely interested in August BAM mmm
campaign we've been working on for a few
months where are we at well I'm pleased
I've managed to kind of round on your
spectator campaign it's crazy agus can't
be sold in America describing in my
speech that if you look at the books it
seems like even President Obama's
connected to some 12th century Scottish
King so I how sad is he can't go feed
his family haggis even on burns night so
we're really keen to move this all
thought it's all wrapped up in this
transatlantic trade investment plan ship
the trade deal in other words that's to
be done we should get haggis in there
lamb venison and many other goods would
you could you do see haggis is a red
line in me and the entire group is
absolutely right and proper that haggis
should not be a criminal thing to sell
an American this is haggis is not
terrorism it shouldn't be a crime to to
sell it and you we need a sensible trade
deal and the reason we need that trade
deals because I shall make us all better
off both sides of the Atlantic that's
got to make sense forever all polls
aren't like great stories in Scotland
using this campaign could ya help shore
up I make an early prediction I don't
usually comment on the polls we may not
win all the Scottish seats but I'm
confident that we can make some progress
with Davison's doing a great great job
up there she's actually really i think
encapsulated the spirit of people who
say actually got a real positive view
for scotland and positive vision for the
way that scotland be part of the united
kingdom with lots of control over its
own affairs which this government has
been central in making sure it gets post
that referendum so I think conservatives
maybe that may be very central to this
coming general election and including
North Ward is less trust as environments
agree on board with the including
madison-based no absolutely she and I
have spoken about it several times seems
to be a bit of a stall and there's a lot
of people saying that it never can
happen it to two minor but it's on the
Tory agenda it is part of these trade
negotiations and the negotiators the
deferent negotiations that let's let's
trust as it is involved with say the
same thing but it is much wider than
haggis we have these extraordinary
terrace both sides import from America
to exports America and then
which is the regulatory costs because we
don't recognize each other's regulatory
regimes that cost businesses it costs
families 10 billion pounds we could add
to our economy 400 pounds make every
family in Britain better off because
lowering prices in the shop and we can
create jobs both sides of the Atlantic
probably a couple of million of them
this is a no-brainer and it's
extraordinary that there are people out
there arguing against it not least the
leader of the Opposition who seems to
think that trade is a bad idea one more
question and when was the last time you
actually I think on Monday night I had
haggis juice very good